voilà dernier grand chapitre de cette
intervention très attendu lui aussi la
confrontation entre Jacques Chirac et
Nicolas Sarkozi et bien le chef de
l'État a voulu réaffirmer son autorité
assez sèchement vous allez l'entendre le
patron c'est moi dit-il en substance
Véronique Saint-Olive Francis
Forget main dans la main Nicolas et
Cécilia Sarkozi accompagné de sa fille
Jeanne sont parmi les T premiers invité
à fouler le tapis rouge de l'Élysée et
pendant près d'une heure le plus
populaire des ministres du
se rép en amabilité Jean tu nous prends
la photo
parfait merci
merci le Sarco show fait recette mais le
ministre des Finances qui n'a pas dit un
mot politique s'éclipse quelques
secondes avant l'interview du président
de la République quelques minutes plus
tard dans son bureau le président de la
République marque son autorité il n'y a
pas de différent
entre le ministre des Finances et moi
pour une raison simple c'est que
notamment s'agissant de la dépense je
décide et il
exécute divergence sur le budget de la
défense polémique sur la présidence de
l'UMP jacquesir Nicolas SAR je vois pas
pourquoi on faitun polémique qui me
paraî beaucoup plus inspiré par des
raisons de politique avec un petit P que
par des raisons de défense de l'intérêt
général je ne laisserai pas les
ambitions ou les calculs des uns ou des
autres ici ou là euh venir perturber
l'action des 3 années à
venir la charge est violente mais sur la
pelouse le Premier ministre
applaudit il y a dans cette intervention
des choses très importantes et il ne
faut pas voir simplement quelques
remises en ordre qu'il fallait faire et
qu' on été faites la Garden Pary est
placée sous le saut de la fraternité
alors certains s'emploient à détendre
l'atmosphère rappelle àordre du patron
voilà rien de bien mais rien de bien
grave loin de là depuis la corise le
premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
est au spectacle qu'il a pu même être
évoqué le petit P de la politique sans
doute parce qu'on voulait viser le petit
s de Nicolas Sarkozi en dilon sur l'état
des relations au sommet de l'État
Nicolas Sarkozi n'a pas encore répliqué
mais à 3 ans des présidentieles ce 14
juillet marque sans doute l'ouverture
officielle de la guerre Chirac Sarkozi